crazy ladies climbing the Statue of
Liberty Facebook categorizing the
Declaration of Independence as hate
speech Democrats decrying the fourth of
July and a record low in American pride
some catastrophize errs say we're on the
verge of a second civil war in reality
we're on the precipice of a third
American Revolution and the court is the
key st. Teresa of Calcutta will weigh in
then the final part of my interview with
North Korean defector and all-around
hero ji sung ho finally the mailbag on
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh sorry excuse me just one second I'm
having a sip of my delicious black rifle
coffee mmm tastes like freedom really
compliments leftist ears very well a
black rifle coffee these guys are so
good we got a welcome this new sponsor
so you know me I defend all of those
liberal left-leaning coffee chains that
charge you a zillion dollars you go into
those places though and you really do
wish that they took about 80% of all
their expenditures which they spend on
like bias training and implicit
unconscious implicit implicit training
and you know all of the like the fourth
gender bathroom they have like they have
the two j'en and they added a third now
they have a fourth gender bathroom you
wish they would stop investing all their
money in that and just spend their money
on making very good delicious coffee
maybe support America a little bit
that's where black rifle coffee comes in
these guys first of all most important
thing they make delicious coffee they
make excellent coffee I've been a coffee
snob
since I was six years old and started
drinking coffee might have stunted my
growth and but I've always liked really
good coffee
they make superb coffee I drink it every
single morning it's really good more
than that though the company is great
founded by a former Special Operations
vets black rifle delivers the best
roasts order coffee right to your door
guarantees you're getting fresh premium
coffee you can get it whole bean you can
get it ground up you can get a Keurig
for those Keurig machines now in
addition to making great coffee and
great coffee gear they also have this
coffee of the Month Club so you know you
just sign up there's no lines there's no
running out you just get great coffee
shipped right to your door every single
month hassle-free it's the black rifle
coffee club when you join that coffee
club you'll get discounts you'll get
other offers not available to their
other customers it makes a superb cup of
coffee
it feels very American you know black
rifle just just delish you know but they
also give a portion of their proceeds to
veteran and First Responder causes so
instead of your money going to like the
the Planned Parenthood Federation of
Namibia or wherever the the other places
donate to these guys you know you're
going to veterans and first responder
causes and you you cannot beat this cup
of coffee
it is as good or better as any cup of
coffee you're gonna get so go to black
rifle coffee dot-com / co' FFA Co V Fe
Fe I know it's confusing isn't it coffee
confess a coffee cough ethnic coffee
coffee black rifle coffee calm / cough
FA Co V Fe Fe the way you can tell the
difference coffee you drink in your
mouth and cofee Fae you know the lines
on the table I'll leave it to your
imagination
black rifle coffee calm / coffe FA for
15% off your order don't say I never did
nothing for you black rifle coffee
dot-com / cough FA what a great sponsor
what a great and I get to drink their
delicious coffee it is so good gob
viously cos Ben hasn't paid me ever you
know other than when I won that bet at
the election last year 2 years ago but
the coffee is so good drink it every day
really really good so how was your 4th
of July was it good I had a very good
4th of July
I was playing it's a grand old flag
marching around my apartment with sweet
little Alisa and then you know saw some
fireworks I don't know hung out with
some pals ate some Omaha steak burgers
that was delicious went over you know
had a couple drinks saw some fireworks
I suspect you had a similar 4th of July
how did the left spend the 4th of July
we actually have video
[Applause]
[Applause]
for those of you who don't subscribe
this is why you have to subscribe there
was a video of a high school kid running
into doorways and banging his head
against the wall bless obviously that
that wonderful girl dubbed by the
Internet is strictly buff screaming that
is how the left spend their 4th of July
I mean it was really really insane they
lost their minds crazy ladies climbing
up the Statue of Liberty even the
Democrat Party issuing this crazy
announcement all of this does have you
realize at least half the country is
unhinged they are really starting to
lose it and you hear all this talk about
is there gonna be a civil war is there
gonna be a civil war I don't think so
but I do think we're on the verge of the
third american revolution we'll get into
that a little bit more later on the
let's start with the crazy lady who
climbed the Statue of Liberty so this is
the new campaign slogan for Democrats
she wore a t-shirt and it said abolish
ice abolish Immigration and Customs
Enforcement this is their new slogan
going into 2018 it's not just the
crazies who climb the Statue of Liberty
it's even US senators who are stating
this so she goes up she climbs the
Statue of Liberty they have to evacuate
Liberty Island you know it she's up
there for like two hours
you know by the way that this woman is
not a New Yorker because New Yorkers
never go to the Statue of Liberty I
lived in New York like all of my life
and never once went to the Statue of
Liberty so she I don't know they bust
him in just like the progressives always
do they busts in some activists shut it
down for everybody who was trying to
have a nice fourth of July and client
waits two hours all day screaming about
how we're separating families at the
border or you know that old Obama that
old Clinton policy of you know you have
to detain the criminals and you can't
throw children in jail so she's
screaming a whole hullabaloo about this
then meanwhile in San Antonio a grown
man went up to a kid who was just
wearing his Magha @as make America great
again hat he's so objected to that
phrase make America great again he goes
up rips the hat off the kid actually
like pulled off some hair with it too
starts screaming this face steals his
hat
think we have a video of that here is
this crazy guy in San Antonio right now
police are looking for that man it was
caught on tape on camera throwing a
drink at a teenager in that video the
man in the red hat and walks off with
the teenagers hat pulled it off so
aggressively he also pulled out some
hair with it I didn't think he was gonna
generate that amount like the amount
like what people are doing like I was
looking at the comments and some people
are like oh yeah like this is uncalled
for and then people were like you know
just mixed opinions but I didn't think
he would blow up to what it is right now
by the way listen this kid is great he's
wearing an American flag bandana you
know he's got braces he's in high school
I assume and he says well when I posted
that video to try to find the guy who
threw a drink in my face ripped off
stole my hat all this well when I posted
it you know a lot of people were
supportive and then there were some
mixed reactions mixed reactions are
those lefties who are like yeah that's
good he should have ripped your head off
you know it's all that craziness and all
that calls for violence coming out of
the left the left has been calling for
violence now pretty explicitly for
several weeks and look at the
juxtaposition you got this kid smile
embraces American flag bandana you know
just an all-around high school kid and
then this crazy adult leftist this
probably unshowered you know hairy
leftist throwing drinks in his face
ripping it off his head stealing his
property that those are the two sides
that you get to look at right now it's
the right with the American flag bandana
and the left ripping off property
screaming vandalizing property climbing
up the Statue of Liberty like a crazy
person now you would think in the midst
of all this Democrats would be freaking
out they'd say oh gosh we were in an
election year we need to offer an
aspirational statement we need to offer
something instead of just this angry
craziness and the calls for if our
lawlessness and open borders that
doesn't seem to play well in Peoria so
what do they do the exact opposite
that's what they do
Democrats issued this fourth of July
statement this is from the DNC they said
quote nearly two and a half centuries
ago a band of patriots gathered in
Philadelphia to declare that all men are
created equal our nation has changed
dramatically since those words were
written on parchment generations of
brave Americans have fought to expand
the promise of equality for more
Americans move our country forward in
its march toward a more perfect union as
we celebrate our nation's independence
we recognize America's founding promise
remains out of reach for too many
families too many members of our society
are still struggling to find a
good-paying job not true by the way we
have a record low unemployment there are
more jobs open than people who are
willing to fill those jobs or the health
care that they need
not true Barack Obama stole health care
from Americans who wanted to keep their
doctor and now we've reversed that let
Americans have their own health care
choice they go on sorry to interrupt
sorry to interrupt Democrats too many
women LGBTQ Americans and by the way I'm
very offended on behalf of the ILA PQ
LMNOP zyx Americans who were not named
by the Democrats you divisive exclusive
monsters they go on people of color
people with disabilities still face
inequality and injustice across our
society what's your evidence for that no
evidence of course but hey they're
Democrats who needs evidence everywhere
we look our most fundamental values are
under attack or that what values Liberty
great more Liberty than ever
economic prosperity good more prosperity
than ever calls to I know that one one
Democrat value I think is booing God
like they did at their national
convention but now we've got more
religious liberty in this land so you
are free to boo God if you want and and
like good people and Christians are free
to worship God thousands of Americans
have been separated from their parents
at our southern border thousands of
children have been separated from their
parents now this isn't quite true I mean
this is a policy that's going on for a
long time now but notice the sleight of
hand here it's not American children
that are being taken from their their
parents it's illegal aliens invading the
country so it doesn't the American Dream
isn't being pulled out of reach for
Americans it's that Americans are
allowed to define their borders to have
borders to say who gets to come into the
country who gets to access welfare
systems who gets to participate in labor
markets who gets to come in when there
are perhaps higher risks of crime total
sleight of hand to conflate this is what
the Democrats do by the way it's why
they changed illegal alien to illegal
immigrant
two undocumented immigrant even illegal
immigrant is ridiculous there's no
illegal immigrant to be an immigrant you
have to be accepted by the country you
late ileal alien is the term they say oh
you know it's really an illegal
immigrant and there are all sorts of
immigrants there are Italian immigrants
there are Irish immigrants there are
illegal immigrants you know they're all
just immigrants aren't they no they go
on them at our highest court workers
rights are being taken away not so
workers are being given rights because
now the workers have a right to decide
if they want to join that union or not
join that union workers are being given
way more rights total life because
voting rights are under assault not so
at all there they're referring to a
voter ID because Democrats usually rely
on the dead and the felonious to win
elections and now we're suggesting
perhaps and they shouldn't be allowed to
do that Muslim Americans are being
discriminated against for their faith
don't see a whole lot of evidence for
that and by the way the the a huge
number of hate crimes in the United
States are against Jews they don't seem
to talk about Jews it's always because
the Democrats have taken this very
strong stance against Israel and in
favor of the the alleged religion of
peace a woman's right to choose is under
threat like never before
a woman's right to choose to kill her
babies of course what they're suggesting
and this gets to the heart of what lies
before the third American Revolution
we'll get to that in a bit the
Democratic Party believes that all
people are created equal no matter who
they are where they come from who they
love or how they pray as we unless
they're Christians in which case they
can't do anything and they have to bake
the cakes and they have to arrange the
flower arrangements and they need to
shut up and stop praying in schools as
we celebrate our nation's independence
Democrats reaffirm our commitment to
fighting for the values of inclusion and
opportunity for everyone except for
patriotic Americans I may be that part
that part was implied at the end so they
issued this very angry negative
statement everything's terrible the
world's going to hell in a handbasket
and and they're focusing on issues that
the American people don't want to focus
on so we know that the vast majority of
Americans don't want amnesty don't want
open borders even for dreamers by the
way and this is true even among
Democrats the majority of Democrats
don't want amnesty even for dreamers
they don't think that should be a
priority for Congress
and yet the Democrats are doubling down
on this they're doubling down on their
radicalism in part it's because Trump
has trolled them into doing this they
just they can't help but take the bait
that he puts out there usually on
Twitter but it's a really weird and
losing strategy and the one day that
we're supposed to all be united the 4th
of July American independence go out and
shoot some fireworks and stop
complaining what do they do they
complain why do they complain on the 4th
of July because they don't like America
they don't like it they're showing their
hand they used to say things like you
know dissent is patriotic so when they
would say anti-american things they
would pretend at least that were
patriotic they're not even doing that
anymore they're not even pretending
they're their anti-americanism
is really right out in front they say we
don't want any borders no you know
America is stolen land you have the head
of the Democrat Party smart one of the
heads of the Democrat Party smiling with
protesters who say that America's stolen
land you know that's the radicalism that
we're seeing and that radicalism I do
understand why some people think we're
headed toward another civil war they
seem to think you know we're so divided
now that both sides are so angry or at
least the left is so angry that
inevitably we're going towards civil war
a CNN CNN brian Stelter the one of the
one of the best characters from CNN you
know that got he looks I'm not gonna
make fun of his looks but one could you
know one certainly could he he was
giving a talk at the Aspen ideas
festival and he's there and and he says
we have a national emergency
right now the Trump presidency is a
national emergency never mind of course
that since President Trump was
inaugurated the Dow is up 5,000 points
never mind that unemployment is at
record lows right now 3.8 percent
unemployment for all those Americans who
are seeing their wealth increase their
freedoms increase and their their
employment prospects increase it doesn't
seem like a national emergency but
there's brian Stelter to remind them
that it is they least in his own fantasy
world and then to round all of that off
according to new polling a record low
percentage of Americans are extremely
proud to be an American there is a
little caveat here 47 percent of
Americans are still extremely proud to
be American just pretty
you know the other word extremely in
there but look America is a country that
really believes in itself it's a country
that was founded as a project so
enthusiasm reigns you know you can have
cynicism were kind of lethargy or apathy
in a place like France you expect that
right a frame like it's called you who
who's come right but not an American
America you have this enthusiasm you say
yeah damn right America Fe a you know
like the song I mean it's really put a
shove a boot in different places and you
know proud to be an American it's a very
enthusiastic place and 47% are still
extremely proud I wonder what that
breakdown is on party lines by the way I
wonder do you think it's just 100 of
full hundred percent of those people who
say they're extremely proud or
Republicans
I might suspect so because the Democrats
have taken such a an explicit
anti-american turn that number forty
seven percent is way down that number
was 70 percent in 2003 now in part of
that there was this real rallying of the
American spirit after the attacks of
9/11 and George W Bush had great moral
leadership at right after that terrorist
attack it unified the country that
number dropped that number stabilized
shortly after 9/11 or after 2003 rather
and it's it's stabilized and it was
pretty stable until 2013 what changed
we I think in the immediate timeline we
can blame Barack Obama for this I like
to blame Barack Obama for just about
anything but this I think he's really
culpable for it's that second Obama term
was just so awful you know usually
presidents in their second term moderate
a little bit they try to unify the
country they try to have a nice legacy
that can buoy them among all segments of
the American people and Obama didn't do
that Fox comm even admits this Fox or
anything he said the the ingenious Obama
second term most presidents moderate he
didn't he doubled down on the first term
so you had these things like foreign
policy and foreign policy he didn't try
to moderate he surrendered to Iran he
surrendered to Korea he gave them he
flew over planes full of you know cases
of cash and gave him a ton of American
assets he bowed down they captured
American sailors in the Persian Gulf he
said oh well
don't don't do that again don't do that
again and in Cuba after a 50-year 60
year embargo policy and not having
normal relations with Cuba he said okay
well we'll open an embassy and we'll
give you everything you want and in
return you give us nothing just do it do
it because we hate ourselves and and
then of course in 2015 a poor the
oberfeld decision that redefined
marriage to include same-sex monogamous
unions but not same-sex polygamous
unions for some reason because Anthony
Kennedy thinks very highly of himself
and it believes he's a romantic poet
after that decision what did Barack
Obama do did he try to unite the country
no he painted the White House in rainbow
lights he was a huge middle finger to
half of the country to people who didn't
want the central institution of society
to be radically redefined by a court
based on nothing based on Anthony
Kennedy's romantic poetry and the
alleged right to intimacy that can be
found and Scalia said clearly there's a
there's an isn't a right to intimacy and
even if there were marriage would not
expand that ask the nearest hippie you
know he just rubbed most of America's
face in this it was such a radicalism
and the real problem with that by the
way isn't even the question of what one
thinks about gay unions or what to call
gay unions or how they should be
interpreted by law the real problem was
flouting the rule of law I'm saying
there's no it doesn't matter what the
rule of law is yeah we're gonna hate
they're gonna look at us with a straight
face the Democrats and say yeah I think
all the founding fathers and the framers
of the Constitution they thought the
Constitution protected monogamous gay
unions and defined marriage that way
that's what they thought you're saying
you don't you couldn't possibly think
that no but no yeah that's what they
thought tell me I'm wrong and that
flouting the rule of law is the real
issue it's it's think of like the
psychology of lines when you're standing
on line at a store and you're waiting to
checkout or something and when people
are on line there's been a lot of
studies about this they don't really
mind if the line is long they don't
really mind if the line is not moving so
long as the line is fair the minute
someone cuts in line people lose their
mind because they've broken the rules
and now
there is chaos people are you you think
I can't rely on these rules anymore
so what's gonna happen people get very
agitated people get very anxious and
people get very tense the the situation
becomes very tense that's what's
happening by flouting the rule of law
this is why when the Democrats say
abolish ice what they're saying is
abolish law enforcement they've been
talking about this for with cops forever
you know abolish police departments
right they want to abolish the rule of
law and it makes everybody very anxious
because when you don't have a rule of
law you have the rule of men and men can
do whatever they want and if the guy
that doesn't like you is in charge then
things probably aren't going to work out
very well for you unless he's bound by
the rule of law this goes back to the
third American Revolution not the Civil
War
we're very lazy for a civil war and
there there aren't equally strong sides
here but there have been three American
revolutions so far the first was the one
in 1776 that began yesterday over two
centuries ago then the second one was
the Civil War this was another American
Revolution this was a this was finishing
the work of the American Revolution that
first revolution was based on natural
rights it was based on the right to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness the
second American Revolution was based on
just that the founding fathers John
Adams predicted that there would be
another American Revolution that they
would have to fight another great war
over the question of slavery because the
premise of the United States was not
born out with the institution of slavery
in place the founding fathers suspected
this the framers knew that this would
happen eventually it happened that same
as she was playing out on the question
of abortion and the question of abortion
is twofold
there's the quest there's roe v wade
there's the question of actually the the
right to an abortion and actually
killing babies and then there's the
question of who can define that right is
the court able to just pretend that
there's some right to an abortion in the
Constitution or if there is to be a
right to an abortion do the
Legislature's have to enact that as a
law because we're a republic and we have
representatives to make laws for us what
is the question and and this question of
abortion is so essential the Democrats
are all losing their mind on this court
seat and over Merrick garland and over
new
Gorsuch because roe v wade is a
ridiculous decision that obviously was
wrongly decided
everybody knows this the left knows this
they're basically admitting it now and
they know that if and if an originalist
or constitutionalist or textualist or
whatever you want to call it is
nominated to the court row v Wade might
be imperiled and that's the question
they're saying this is all about this
one decision but that if the decision
isn't just awful for itself it's awful
also for what it says about American law
and that anxiety that it brought to
American law here is mother Theresa st.
Teresa of Calcutta explaining the the
merits of of it itself the question of
abortion itself then we'll get to it in
the American system here's st. Theresa
but I feel that the greatest destroyer
of peace today is abortion because jesus
said if you receive a little child you
receive me so every abortion is that
denial of receiving Jesus did the
neglect of receiving Jesus it is really
a war against the child and I hate
killing of the innocent child murder by
the mother herself and if we accept that
the mother can kill even our own child
how can we tell other people not to kill
one another by abortion the mother does
not learn to love but kills even her own
child to solve her problems and by
abortion
the father is told that it does not have
to take any responsibility at all for
the child
he has brought into the world that so
that father is like you put other women
into the same trouble
so abortion just leads to more abortion
any country that accepts abortion is not
teaching its people to love one another
but to use any violence to get what they
upon Jesus was the greatest destroyer of
love
and peace is abortion so true and she
said this st. Teresa said this in 1994
at the National Prayer Breakfast this
was major international headlines she
mother Teresa says the greatest
destroyer of peace is abortion seems
like such a such a minor thing it's such
a small little being that you're
snuffing out oh it's a privacy issue and
but it operates on twofold abortion
begets more abortion and the awful
jurist the perverse jurisprudence that
led to the roe v wade decision begets
more perverse jurisprudence that
threatens the liberty of the United
States
what paved the way for the roe v wade
decision was Griswold v Connecticut 1965
where Justice William O Douglas found
quote the foregoing cases suggest that
specific guarantees in the Bill of
Rights have penumbra's formed by
emanations from those guarantees that
help give them life in substance now to
translate that into English I'll tell
you what he actually said he said blah
blah blah blah blah blah gobbled
accompaniment above that's what he said
it's absurd the number is like a shade
you know it should sort of shaded area
shadow that goes out and the emanations
coming from those guarantees so you're
saying yes there's no right to an
abortion in the Constitution but you
know I like certain parts of the
Constitution and I like abortion and you
know they're probably connected somehow
so let's say that there's a right to
abortion and now that that case by the
way Griswold v Connecticut was not a bad
abortion it was about to contraception
whether laws can ban the use of
contraceptives and they found this
generalized right to privacy which does
not exist anywhere in the Constitution
and and the fact that that decision roe
v wade remains on the books such a
monumental such a consequential decision
such an absurd illogical nonsense
decision it has led to further crazy
jurisprudence and we have to respect it
by the by story decisis some say but
some decisions are so egregious that
they have to be overturned it the
abortion begets more abortion and
perversity and perverse jurisprudence
begets more perverse jurisprudence you
know by 2015 support for the Supreme
Court a hit an all-time low in the
United States trust in this
Court is an institution why did it hit
an all-time low because with those sorts
of decisions it became clear that the
Supreme Court was not interpreting the
law the Supreme Court was writing law
and writing consequential law and pretty
horrific law revolutions happen because
of natural rights in the United States
that's what they're about
John Thomas Jefferson said frequently I
said from time to time the tree of
liberty must be refreshed with the blood
of patriots and tyrants it's a pretty
graphic image pretty vivid image and
that certainly was the case in the first
American Revolution it was certainly the
case in the second American Revolution
we can hope that in this third American
Revolution that I hope we embarked upon
that there will not be more blood
spilled but that the blood that has been
spilled since the roe v wade decision
will cease to be spilled that that will
act as enough spilled blood for that
revolution because we're on the cusp of
it and we can either turn away from it
if President Trump nominates some squish
in the model of Justice Kennedy will
continue down the path of perverse
jurisprudence and the erosion of Liberty
and the erosion of life and if he
nominates an originalist who's gonna
read the text and tell us what it means
then we might be able to recapture some
of that Liberty we might be able to
protect life without which liberty and
the pursuit of happiness means nothing
we can only hope that the Democrats are
losing their mind because of this
they're losing their mind because this
tyranny is is possibly going to come to
an end this tyranny there was tyranny
before the first revolution there was
tyranny before the second and there has
been a tyranny of of men since this
awful jurisprudence has gone into effect
we've become much more nation of men
Congress has abdicated its
responsibility the president leads by
executive Fiat this was note most noted
under Barack Obama the Congress has
abdicated its responsibility the court
rules by Fiat the court has abandoned
its loyalty to the Constitution so it
would rule as the rule of men there's a
tyranny that's coming to an end it's
brought around a lot of leftist policy
Praga tips that might be coming to an
end they're losing their minds it might
look pretty bad now but it looked pretty
bad in the early days of the American
Revolution and the Civil War - it looked
pretty bad and so you say all we're
divisive we hate each other well let's
just all calm down maybe calm down or
maybe we should try to do something here
and maybe you know those people who say
calm down president Trump just a point
some squishy guy that'll then
people know don't pacify them don't
pacify them do the right thing do the
right thing and we might have a chance
to keep keep up American liberty and
American Life because it seems that
we're at a turning point
I've ran a little bit late now I've got
to bring you speaking of life and
liberty the final part of my interview
with chief ssam ho the defector and the
the director of the film that is now the
documentary film that is covering aji
Seung hos life and journey without
further ado ji Seong ho hawk thank you
for coming on Hawk Johnson you've been a
filmmaker for 19 years
journalist writer producer you you've
been around Hollywood you've been around
the industry journeymen what led you to
this story other than that it's the most
inspiring story certainly in my lifetime
what what led you to it how did you get
involved and tell us a little bit about
the project sure well I mean this
specific episode we've been filming this
short form documentary for witness
project we've been shooting with ji
Xiang Hao is Epis next round of episodes
we're doing for the series called
witness project which is an original
series put out by victims of communism
Memorial Foundation I'm familiar with
that if a case of communism you know
foundation yeah and you always hear
about victims of Nazism with victims but
for some reason victims of communism
even though we can see these
unbelievable stories of hell on earth to
just get getting out and getting to
freedom for some reason that doesn't get
a lot of play in the media why and I got
the call so I mean I started a
documentary film company about six years
ago because I was working mainstream
here and I was just kind of tired of the
vacuous aspect of the storytelling and
sort of the one side is aspect of the
storytelling I just had a I've always
had an independent opinion on matters
and by the way for those watching that
means conservatives like the difference
of opinion I mean there's there is there
is a a main way of thinking on in the
the LA film industry and if you think
differently conservative or otherwise
you are authorized and it is it is
something that you have to overcome as a
filmmaker and as an artist as someone
who's expressing themselves and so I got
a phone call number years ago saying
like hey we've got these stories they're
there they're building effectively a
museum kind of a Holocaust doll museum
for the victims of communism and you
know the Cold War ended and there
propensity just leave those stories like
who wants to remember the past who wants
to think about this and then and it and
enough times gone by you know 20 30
years where I started seeing that the
those oral stories were starting to die
out weren't being captured weren't being
brought to the sort of historically
significant level of being known to sort
of the cultural literacy and it just
really struck me that it was an
important underserved part of
storytelling and so I took on the
project witness project and it was
really looking at the first person
primary source people who experienced
these things I mean there's more than
one type of evil in the world and these
stories are important to capture and you
have to go to the source and so I
actually really looked at it and thought
about it as the journey of the dissident
I mean everything in this town is based
off of the hero's journey right I mean
every feature film is the ordinary world
the call to adventure the rejection of
the call the meeting of the mentor the
acceptance of the call you know then you
have the ordeal the belly the Beast the
reward the road home that's every
feature film every feature film right
and we have to know that Pat what you
make films in this town and so I took it
looked at as the journey of the
dissident where near live in a
collective Schlow society and your
individuality has been crushed there is
a journey of that awakening within and
you know well before the external 6,000
miles dragging yourself through the
jungle there's the sort of you're
mapping the world you're being fed to
propaganda and you know there's there's
only one God the Dear Leader and then
there's a sort of you start to learn you
start to map world the world out for
your own mind and there's cognitive
dissidence there's what you've been told
and oh no you you have realized and
that's the first threshold of coming out
as a dissident coming out as an activist
you're like huh things are different and
the entire communist system is designed
to try and stop you from thinking at
that moment and so I thought well how do
we show that threshold how do we show
that internal awakening that happens
before the first steps taken when you
cross the border to it Jia Shan host
case across the border to China and
start that step-by-step process so then
and then the second much like the
meeting of the mentor the first time you
decide to say something out loud first
time you said I do express yourself
that's life or death you think hmm
this doesn't seem to compute they don't
seem to be
the total leader you say it to them you
say it to your parents you say it's your
brother you say it's your sister whoever
your friend if you a HAP if you happen
to choose incorrectly that could mean
death that could be re-educated they
could be loss of reputation could be
loss of ability to support yourself I
mean it's a very profound journey that
happens internally so I look at the
internal and the external is sort of a
two part aspect of my storytelling of
course yeah I think somehow was was
talking about that to the the spiritual
aspect you know this kind of internal
aspect and then obviously the external
horrors when when can we see this you
know obviously we've gotten to hear a
little bit about this story when can we
see this and how are we gonna make sure
that the American people can see this
and this historically important matter
that for so long
hasn't really been talked about yeah
well we just wrapped a great series
production days filming this and we're
going to be working on post-production
for a number of months and we'll figure
it and so probably the next six months
will come out with this episode maybe
less and and we're working on
distribution for right now in terms of a
worldwide distribution but right now
it's currently available victims of
communism has a website you know slash
witness Smok media we have we also have
portals to the same aspect and we're
just sort of building building our
cultural base and understanding of that
world of closed societies of communist
collectivist societies and the
oppression so it's a great space to kind
of start learning how how oppression
works on the left side of the spectrum
well hawk it is so wonderful that you
were using the tools of Hollywood to
convey it in important stories that
aren't being told to enter to bring
about a lot of good by uncovering a lot
of evil I mean it is so wonderful I've
been out here for a little while and
that isn't what Hollywood does that just
Hollywood just never does that so that's
really wonderful I can't wait to see it
and sungho you are doing God's work man
it is a singular privilege of my life to
get to meet you
thank you thanks Lance thank you both
pretty cool to talk to those guys and
great to see some good stuff coming out
of Hollywood too as they're making this
documentary about it you saw probably on
the 4th of July James Woods outspoken
Hollywood conservative James Woods this
agent dropped him he said it's the 4th
of July I don't want to represent you
anymore Mary Wright right that's that's
Hollywood for you so it's good to see
some good stuff coming out of Hollywood
and you know I guess it's kind of it's
too bad for the movie industry because
James Woods is such a good actor but at
least now he'll have more time to be on
Twitter and he's a very good tweeter too
so that'll be enjoyable breaking news
now the EPA chief Scott Pruett has
resigned President Trump has accepted
his resignation Democrats have been
gunning for this guy forever because he
was a strong D regulator he was really
undoing a lot of the insane and
tyrannical Obama administration agenda
of using the EPA in particular but the
executive agencies to pet to basically
regulate all of Americans lives to in
effect pass laws that run Americans
lives and he did a great job I'm sorry
to see him go
Andy wheeler the deputy PA chief will
take over in his place and I hope he's
related to Liz wheeler I don't know
maybe that'd be kind of cool wouldn't it
good sturdy Texas Constitution anyway
it's too bad to see him go he did a
great job and they smeared him and he
withstood the smearing for a while but
these guys who were who were trying to
regain some American Liberty it really
they're sacrificing a lot because their
lives basically get ruined by the left
so good on you Scott good good job for
what you did we've got to say goodbye to
Facebook in YouTube go to daily wire.com
right now it is 10 bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me you
get the end reclaim ensure you get them
in Shapiro show you have to ask
questions in the mailbag which is coming
up we got a solid ten minutes left where
we can talk about that but none of that
matters hmm oh that tastes like a judge
justice Amy Kony Barrett doesn't does
that taste like it tastes like the news
headline justice Amy Kony Barrett and
then the deluge that comes down from all
the lefties there's leftist tears delish
very good we can we can only hope
I go to daily wire guy come get your
leftist here's tumblr we'll be right
back with a mailbag
I'm running late so let's get right into
it with the mailbag from Alex dear st.
Michael of the silent word bringer of
all left us tears I implore you I've
become acquainted with a cutie 3.14
anybody get that with a cutie pie bearer
of 2x Alice Ohm's chromosomes Alice
Ohm's I don't know by means of my church
choir and I must say that she tickles my
fancy what with her devotion to the
risen Christ and her many gifts from God
and let's say well played I feel as
though I ought to make a move on this
woman but I'm hindered by my adherence
to the notion that the church is
supposed to be a place of devotion to
our Lord our God and not a place to
fraternize I feel as though if I were to
attempt to form a relationship with a
woman who I've come to know through
church events I'd be in a sense
degrading the institution but then again
if not through Catholic related events
how on God's green earth am I supposed
to find a marry a Catholic woman please
help me solve this dilemma I'm happy to
help you solve this I'll read a Genesis
chapter 1 verse 28 and God blessed them
and God said to them be fruitful and
multiply and fill the earth and subdue
it and have dominion over the fish of
the sea and over the birds of the
heavens and over every living thing that
moves on the earth you know it's not
good for man to be alone man needs a
mate and that's why God gave Adam a mate
and seems to have maybe given you one
now here's the important thing because I
understand you don't you you're worried
about being inappropriate in the church
or being irreverent some things are
inappropriate in the church acoustic
guitars that song about the eagle's
wings applause and those things are
inappropriate in a church marrying a
woman and just populating it with lots
of little Catholic babies very
appropriate to begin that in a church so
now that I will get there's one caveat
here which is if you're in this choir
with her and you really obviously you
don't want to be like too distracted
during the during the mass buddy you
know try to keep your eyes on the prize
but afterward or at the little coffee
afterward or whatever you're going to do
it's good to think about other things
and you know how to
how to follow God's commands on this
earth because you're in this choir with
her and it's you know you're focused on
God you just got to be kind of cool
about it like don't be weird about it
you know you don't want you want to go
up and ask her out and be confident
maybe that'll go well and if she is
really not interested then you you know
unfortunately you got to let it go but
there is there is nothing in I've read
the Catechism of the Catholic Church
I've read the Bible I've read some some
of the Church Fathers there is nothing
that says that you cannot pick up a cute
lady and populate God squares quite the
opposite pal go forward in Genesis 1:28
let me know how it goes from Cameron to
The Daily wires homegrown gov own a week
ago you made a distinction between a
conservative and a constitutional
Supreme Court justice and while I agree
with you in principle I'm having some
trouble getting my mind around the
example you used you said that a
conservative justice would ban abortion
outright but a constitutional or
textualist or originalist justice would
simply overturn roe v wade and kick the
law making to the states i'm not a
constitutional scholar but it seems to
me that if you accept the premise that
abortion is the killing of unborn
children as i think i've heard you say
on the show then states don't have the
right to allow it again I'm no expert
but it seems crazy to me
that the Constitution leaves space for
the states to legalize the killing of
any subject of its population arguments
about the death penalty set aside for
the sake of the question what am I
missing here thanks Cameron you're
missing federalism most murders are
state crimes they're not federal crimes
that's why we have a federal system in
the Constitution
so not everything hateful and odious is
covered by some provision of the
Constitution now find me a state that
doesn't consider murder a crime good
luck you probably won't but that's not a
matter for the federal government to
decide that's regulated by the states
with some exceptions there are some
murders that are that are federal crimes
but when when they're not you leave it
to the States
and if you believe in federalism then
you'll suspect that most states will
come to the come to see the light and
come to a reasonable conclusion but
that's why not everything is Scalia once
told me at former the lake right Justice
Scalia
not everything hateful and odious is
covered by some provision of the
Constitution and you got to be okay with
that because
that's that's central liberty premise in
the Constitution and and if you don't
like that then you really just become
the flipside of the lefty people who
want to twist the Constitution now
that's probably better I'd rather have a
conservative twist the Constitution than
a lefty twist the Constitution but what
I really want is for the document to
speak for itself and for the document to
be interpreted with the original meaning
that it had the original public meaning
at the time that it was ratified from
Haley that a little bit more time who do
you think should be chosen for Supreme
Court for the Supreme Court
Amy Kony Barrett that's who I think
she's terrific I think there are a lot
of good options out there and it looks
like the shortlist is down to three some
the other people seem okay she seems to
be the most rock-ribbed she seems to be
the most sure thing on a personal level
and you know optics do matter that the
personality does matter because the you
know we they will be going through a
confirmation process this will play out
on a political stage she's just it
appears unimpeachable and terrific
she raised seven children while becoming
a federal judge she's takes her religion
seriously Dianne Feinstein said that the
what if what is it the dogma lives
loudly within her works for me and and
she's been through this vetting process
very recently the same process so I
think it'd be good and I think it would
be it'd be nice to have someone that we
can rely upon to be an originalist on
the court and she seems pretty
rock-ribbed this isn't to say that the
others are awful but she's got my
support from Keegan hi pretty boy
Knowles hey Keegan me and my friend are
having a small argument over Israel and
Palestine he keeps saying that the
Israelis want to invade and claim the
Palestinians lands which is complete
asininity what would be some simple
points to point out to him over this
matter okay well you're right it's
completely ridiculous
the Israelis couldn't invade
Palestinians land because there's no
such thing as Palestinians land there's
no such country as Palestine it's to the
left of Wakanda and to the east of
Narnia it's utter nonsense the the great
leader of Palestine Yassir Arafat was
born in Egypt he's an Egyptian there's
no such thing it's a contrived crisis
Korea
by arabs who opposed the existence of
israel it's really sad that other Arab
nations have allowed some people who now
call themselves the Palestinian people
to live in squalor and to as a as a
cudgel to try to attack the State of
Israel the Islamic religion has no claim
on Jerusalem whatsoever and the
Palestinian dilemma will only be
resolved when the Arab states around it
want peace and the Arab states around it
appear not to want peace it's utterly
contrived and and we shouldn't we
shouldn't mistake the crocodile tears of
Islamic tyrannical nations around them
as anything but what they are which is
uncompassionate and and a cudgel against
a legitimate flourishing democratic
state in the region from Ryan I'm
Michael in the Catholic faith it is of
the utmost importance to be open to
having children when getting married
would Catholicism be more in favour of a
homosexual couple getting married with
plans to have children or a heterosexual
couple getting married with no plans to
have children most of that question is
nonsense by the light of the Catholic
Church and this is because the debate
over whether to have gay marriage or not
is not whether gay people should have
the right to get married but what what
marriage means and the definition of
marriage that has existed for all of
human history is that sexual difference
in hears in marriage and so if you don't
have sexual difference then you don't
have marriage you have something else
but it isn't marriage so the two the
first part that couldn't happen for the
heterosexual couple a sexually different
couple who are getting married and have
no plans to have children you have to be
open to children for that to be a
sacrament if you're not open to children
then it isn't then you aren't getting
married in the light of the Catholic
Church and this is this they are very
hard line about this I mean this is a
hard line rule if somebody has is
incapable of having children not that
you know perhaps it won't work out or
there it seems that they're barren or
something like that but if it is like
they're missing half of their body
they're only a torso up to a head you
can't get married that's not a little
that isn't it legit
marriage in the eyes of the Catholic
Church you have to be open to it now
what does that mean some people say oh I
don't know that I want to have kids and
in like five seconds later they start
their brood I've got some friends who
are like that so I don't think I want to
have kids until now and now I'm gonna
have like ten of them so that you know
things can change like that but you must
be open to the possibility of life and
if you're not then it's not marriage now
if you were let's say two people get
married and one is post-menopause and I
don't know one it is it isn't looking
and some doctor said you probably not
gonna have kids that doesn't take out
the logical possibility of life that
doesn't you know that that is still that
could still be a legitimate marriage but
when it's not logically possible it's
not a marriage can I take one more do I
have time for one more one more you say
okay I'll do it
from Sean is it true that the only thing
that flat-earthers have to fear is the
sphere itself
great question this is why you tuned in
to this show for real important bits of
insight like that that might that might
well be true I do want to mention
something about the flat earthers though
because this arcs me all the time you
always hear lefties compare
conservatives to flat earthers they say
oh you know in the old times the people
thought the earth was flat and what's
great is that the real flat earthers
meaning people who denied basic
realities of the world the real flat
earthers are the people who promote the
flat earther myth in the old timey days
nobody thought the earth was flat people
have known that the earth is spherical
since the 6th century before Christ and
Aristotle that was Pythagoras who
suggested that Aristotle has provided
evidence that the earth is spherical
since the 4th century before Christ
there's this myth that people in the old
timey days like in the Middle Ages
thought the earth was flat this was put
forward by John William Draper who's a
scientist I Andrew Dickson Dwight who
was an educator and Washington Irving
whom I loved
good essayist and biographer but dead
wrong about this it's just a it's one of
these tools that the lefties use to try
to make it seem like we moderns you know
we moderns have iPhones so clearly we're
much smarter and more educated than
those crazy Middle Ages people not true
the people in the Middle Ages medieval
philosophers were much much smarter than
you and I Thomas Aquinas is much smarter
than you and I
and it's just a total lie so I let
whenever they say that say you know you
are using that phrase to call people
from the past idiots and you are using
it to demonstrate that you yourself are
an idiot
on that note we have so many more
questions we're not going to get to them
I have a good weekend I hope you enjoy
the 4th of July's like nice abbreviated
week I'm gonna get back to my solid 72
hours of of loafing around and not doing
anything then I'll see you on Monday I
hope you have a good weekend in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolan show the Michael Nolt show
is produced by seniya Villarreal
executive producer Jeremy bori
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austen Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Meena
hair and makeup is by Jeshua all Vera
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
for word publishing production copyright
for word publishing 2018
you